the 2010s was a rollercoaster of a
decade for film he saw Disney dominating
at the box office but we also saw the
rise of streaming and the decline of
movie ticket sales despite the fact that
so many amazing films were produced we
did manage to narrow down our list so
without any further ado here are our top
10 movies of the 2010s number 10 call me
by your name the mood have called me by
your name mirrors the hot and relaxing
Italian summer days that are depicted in
the film set in 1983 call me by your
name tells the story of the slow burn
romance between two young lovers Elio
and Oliver Luca Guadagnino stylized
direction is entrancing as are the
performances by army hammer and Timothy
sha'lame and the movie also features
Michael Stuhlbarg delivering one of
cinema's all-time great monologues call
me by your name is a realistic depiction
of young love that is amplified by
several tender original songs from
Sufjan Stevens all in all any movie that
can forever changed the way that society
looks at peaches is a film worth
celebrating
number nine eighth grade being yourself
can be hard and it's like aren't I
always being myself seeing life itself
play out with such specific detail can
be scary which is exactly what 8th grade
delivers the film follows Kayla day in
her last week of eighth grade dealing
with the difficult moments that this
time of life brings she looks forward to
the next big step high school and like
everyone she wants to be cool and
confident the honesty of the film rests
heavily on the shoulders of Elsie Fisher
who plays Kayla her performance is
painfully recognizable from the
stuttering to the subtlest of eye
twitches this film is very specifically
of its time Kayla deals with social
media technology and changing social
attitudes but bo burnham scripts somehow
also captures something both individual
and universal even if you haven't lived
as a middle schooler in the time of
YouTube videos or the pervasive use of
the internet even if you haven't
experienced the joys and pains of
American girlhood firsthand at the heart
of the film is an experience that we can
all relate to one of anxiety wanting to
be liked and having absolutely no idea
what we're doing
number eight spider-man into the
spider-verse
what makes you different is what makes
you spider-man when talking about
spider-man into the spider verse we have
to talk about the visuals and the
technical achievement of pulling off the
wildly artistic vision of the art
directors the animation is the bold
combination of an uber saturated 2d
comic book with its grid light color
cells and the more realistic 3d
computer-generated animation it's
visually stunning and quite simply like
nothing we've ever seen before but
visuals can only carry a movie so far
into the spider-verse
also fully delivers on story which is a
tough challenge for any film but
especially a film released in this
context we've seen far too many
iterations of spider-man in less than
two decades and frankly the zeitgeist is
a bit fatigued by the constant reboots
in addition to the humorous and whip
smart script one of the main reasons the
spider film is so fresh is because our
spider protagonist isn't Peter Parker at
all he's Miles Morales a young
afro-latino kid from Brooklyn bitten by
a different radioactive spider spider
verse is the best animated film of the
decade because despite all the cards
stacked against it it's somehow the most
original number 7 the florida project
the brightly colored cinematography in
the florida project contrasts with the
heavy nature of the film subject to
create a darkly beautiful film about
childhood the film is about Mooney a six
year old girl living with her struggling
mother in one of the motels near Disney
World the fully realised characters are
the heart of this film and are elevated
by the amazing performances by Willem
Dafoe and the rest of the cast which is
especially impressive considering that
no one besides Tufo had ever acted
before in a film like in his previous
film tangerine Shaun Baker acts as
writer director and editor proving that
he is a master of his craft additionally
he avoids exploiting the subject matter
of poverty in his film through an
extremely honest and unbiased depiction
of his characters there are no
protagonist and no antagonist just
people Baker has figured out how to
distill these seemingly simple moments
into an extraordinary film number 6 the
social network
[Music]
he's directed so many masterpieces at
this point that it seems rather
superfluous to praise David Fincher but
when you combine Fincher with an Aaron
Sorkin screenplay the result is
something that should probably be
acknowledged and revered which is
exactly what we get with a social
network on a surface level the social
network is about the rise of Mark
Zuckerberg and Facebook but the film is
much more interested in the human aspect
of the story as Sorkin said the
invention itself is as modern as it gets
but the story is as old a storytelling
themes of friendship loyalty jealousy
class and power Fincher bringing
Sorkin's neo Shakespearean screenplay to
life perfectly balancing a dozen
characters nonlinear storytelling and
intertwining narrative arcs Jesse
Eisenberg delivers his best performance
ever and when you put all of those
elements together you get an outstanding
film that will hopefully outlive
Facebook itself number five
Lady Bird Greta Gerwig and Saoirse Ronan
are a match made in Indy Hollywood
heaven
Lady Bird carries the same wit and tone
we've seen in films girl Rika starred in
but with her at the reins as writer and
director we get a window into her soul
as she shows us the painful and
endlessly funny rollercoaster that is
the life of a teenage Catholic school
rebel this semi-autobiographical film is
crammed full of genuine moments
showcasing the good bad and ugly aspects
of family friendship and growing up
Ronan once again proved that she is one
of the most talented actresses ever and
works perfectly with Laurie Metcalf to
nail their contentious mother-daughter
relationship dynamic gerweck shows that
she's talented beyond her years as Lady
Bird shrewdly explores family dynamics
and social status and an extremely
honest and entertaining film number four
Mad Max fury road
sigh King
who would have thought that an artistic
feminist movie from the man who made
Happy Feet would not only be one of the
best action films of the decade but one
of the best films of all time
well Mad Max fury road is all of that
and more set in the not-so-distant
dystopian future
Mad Max has a fairly straightforward
plot Max and furiosa attempt to outrun
and escape the warlord important Joe and
his deadly Caravan technically the film
is flawless it's acting directing stunts
editing and choreography are all
top-notch the film's stripped-down plot
allows room for the action to really
shine Mad Max has more memorable moments
in one five-minute action sequence than
other action movies have in their entire
runtime the film is wild immersive and
hardly ever slows from its full throttle
action insanity number three
boyhood
one of the many things that makes
boyhood exceptional is that it was
filmed over a 12-year period a singular
and Herculean filmmaking achievement but
boyhood probably would have had a very
good shot of making our top ten list
even if it was produced like a regular
film due to Richard Linklater's
beautiful storytelling boyhood follows
the day-to-day life of a boy Mason
played by other Coltrane who started
filming at the age of six and finished
at the age of eighteen Linklater created
a fulfilling narrative slowly piecing it
together as they filmed every summer
from 2002 to 2013 Patricia Arquette
deservedly won the Academy Award for
Best Supporting Actress and Ethan Hawke
turned in one of his routinely
outstanding performances as well a
totally unique approach to creating a
film combined with Arquette Hawke and
Linklater at the height of their powers
created the stellar one-of-a-kind
masterpiece number 2 moonlight
[Music]
from director Barry Jenkins moonlight
follows Shiro a boy living in the
projects of Miami as he grapples with
his harsh home life and a sexuality the
film's earnest script is complemented by
a dreamy pastel color palette an aching
score from Nicolas Patel and an
outstanding cast from top to bottom
including an Academy award-winning
performance from a Hersh lolly it was
also the first Academy Award Best
Picture winner to feature an all-black
cast and the first one that had a
prominent LGBT theme moonlight is a
beautiful and deeply moving depiction of
masculinity every aspect of the film is
perfect and yet somehow it still manages
to be more than the sum of its parts
a magnum opus for everyone involved
number one get out so how long is this
been going on
writer and director Jordan Peele
announced himself as an auteur with get
out a mystery thriller that is a spot-on
commentary about race in America get out
begins with a black photographer Chris
tentatively agreeing to go visit and
meet with his white girlfriend's family
for the first time her family seems nice
on the surface but Chris can't help but
notice that something seems strange
about her parents house peel script is
tense funny and rewards viewers for
repeat viewings with dozens of Easter
eggs but more than anything it's an
incredibly sharp critique of liberal
racism in the lie of a post-racial
America we think this film is the best
of the decade for being exceedingly
clever thrilling rewatchable and for its
scathing and poignant social commentary
so what did you think of our list
what's your favorite let us know in the
comments